同学们我们又见面了
而且今天是这整个歌词创作班的最后一堂课
首先呢我们一样来分享一首韵脚诗
今天分享的韵脚诗叫舍去
誓言进程
舍利需要累世多少回忆
我真的害怕来不及累积爱你之外的舍去
草原上的风继续青春不断在长成
秋季
当生命落尽冰封
大地纯白而又锋利的岂止是过去
于是我将泪密封在琥珀里
透明着永不老去的爱你
同学们有没有注意到我
韵脚诗的最后一个重点都是压在最后的段落
那这一首的重点在最后的两行
于是我将泪密封在琥珀里
透明着永不老去的爱你
琥珀大家都知道他是一个树脂
树上的树脂的结晶
琥珀是不会老去的
琥珀有时候封住了一只昆虫
一只古代的生物
然后几百年甚至上万年出土之后
那个生物还栩栩如生
那只蜘蛛还看得到形状
泪是液体
所以我将琥珀把泪封住了
透明的
看得到类
他再也不会老去了
这段爱情再也不会老去了
这个就是思迷人的地方
那很鼓励哥同学去创作韵脚师
因为这样子的文字洁净度很高
而且呢等到你掌控到一定能力的时候
你可以把韵脚式的结构词汇转成歌词来使用
爱你的歌词会让人家觉得耳目一新
用这样的词汇结构语法去形容爱情
好特别的文字观点
这个就是风格
是我创作韵脚诗的风格
当然咯
我希望各位同学将来你也会有属于自己的风格
既然是最后一堂课了
那我们先来做个小小的复习
同学们记得哦
第一个13种听觉韵脚先去掌握它
然后再把这13种听觉韵脚去整理成
扩充成两本韵脚工具书
其中一本就是数据类的
所以数据类你可以上网去查同一个韵脚
归类在这听觉韵脚里面的范畴内
这是一本另外一本跟韵脚无关
而是主题式的收集
最好是用文字
用文字收集的
这本呢是跟内容画面有关
可能在pop里面
夜店里面触目所及的元素就把它收罗齐备
这个叫主题式的韵脚
只有两本
一个是数据类的
一个是主题类的
在随身携带一本灵感小册子
灵感小册子就是想到什么经典的句子就记下来
不管它是完整的一句结构还是单字
都可以记得哦
两本工具书
一本灵感小册子
还有记得五结构三要素
哪五结构
画面态度
情感情绪跟故事线
这里需要跟各位同学说明一下
这五结构里面少了一个意境
因为不是每首歌都有意境
很多平铺直树的歌像告白气球一样
你很难有意境
告白气球是因为旋律很强
撑住了歌词的我认为的缺点
但我还是强调
有些很口语的词汇是适合出现在副歌
只是以专业作词者的态度
好像就觉得好像可以更好
虽然这首歌有一定程度的传唱度
但我还是觉得说副歌重唱的时候应该可以更好
就是自我的一种追求
也因此呢
各位同学不妨把五结构里面的情感抽走
改成意境
就是画面态度
意境情绪
故事性
这是三要素
三要素
第一就是人生代词的使用
再来是韵脚文字的掌握
还有情感的最大公约数
五结构三要素
另外还要复习的是先词后曲的时候
要记得曲式
音乐的曲式的掌握
你就能先词后曲
a one a two或a one完之后直接唱副歌V有可能
所以呢先词后曲的先决条件是
你要掌握音乐的曲式
常见的趋势
还有韵脚的段落灵活使用
你可以124押韵
你可以一二压一个韵脚
三是压个韵脚
这是要复习的地方
最后一个环节
记得我提过的一些诗人
不管这个诗人是古代的
是现代的
他们的词风都是我自己吸收的目标
比如说可能下雨
下雨的文字洁净度就像钻石一样
非常的高
段落是跳跃的
蒙太奇的剪接
就文字的简介感很强
另外是席慕蓉
文字很凄美
悲伤的很凄美
暗恋的很凄美
完全迥异的创作风格
还有古代三个词人
柳永
李煜
李清照
这个词人的作品
是我们创作歌词的时候吸收和学习的对象
今天分享的课程议题是
当一个有故事可以说的人
这样子的主题其实适用在各个领域
不是只有学习歌词
因为人生就是一趟旅行
旅行中你会遇到不同的风景
你跟风景的互动就会留下记忆
而这个记忆就是你故事的一部分
在这里跟大家分享一个人生的态度
就是当个有故事可以说的人
首先分享的概念是一个人最大的悲哀
就是不愿意当自己
你都否定自己的
都不想要当自己的
你的快乐的动力跟来源在哪里
你没有引擎的吗
就是你每天醒来就接受啊
我再瘦一点多好啊
我再高一点多好
我学历再强一点多好
我存款里面的数字再多一点多好
我朋友圈再扩展一点多好
你每天在想这些自己没有办法掌握的条件
或者暂时没有办法拥有的条件
你怎么会有努力向上的动力和热情呢
举个例子
就像一只乌龟好了
它每天醒来都在想说
我是一只兔子多好
就像兔子一样跑得快多好
他就是乌龟马
他想了一年两年
它也不会变成兔子啊
但是它可以成为乌龟里面爬最快的
它可以变成一只有性格的乌龟
猎食技巧最好的乌龟静止不动时
最稳的乌龟不吃不喝
醉酒的乌龟都可以
但是它就不会变成兔子吗
就是这样子
所以呢接受自己所有的先天条件
是想要快乐的最基本的前提
再跟大家分享一句话
就是我从村上春树的小说
海边的卡夫卡里面看到的
人生就是因为不能随心所欲
所以才有趣
我看到这句话的时候
想了老半天
你知道吗
就像我相信我的歌词创作班
一定有很多特别的句子
你把它抄下来了
当做一个生活上的对照
或某种程度的座右铭一样
学习就是这样子
截取你要的部分
记住你觉得特别的地方
那这句话觉得好特别哦
人生就是因为不能随心所欲
所以才有趣哦
我在想一个心想事成的人生难道不好吗
因为不能随心所欲
所以才有趣嘛
后来想想
对他讲的没有错
一个心想事成的人生有多可怕
你知道吗
因为呢你只要许愿
比如说班级篮球大赛
然后呢你们班就许愿
许愿说啊
我们如果班级篮球大赛可以拿到总冠军多好
你就是许愿嘛
你想要心想事成嘛
结果呢三个月后颁奖典礼上
你们办真的是总冠军
我告诉你在颁奖典礼上念到你的名字的时候
你们整体不会雀跃
不会感动
不会挥泪
因为是许愿得来的过程中
你们没有训练
你们没有同台阶努力挥汗的记忆
完全没有下了课
大家用自己的时间去练篮球
练完了一起去吃冰
在这个过程这样子这个记忆的风景
你们完全没有
因为没有没有争取
没有危害
没有努力
那个成果拿的很心虚
不会抱在一起痛哭
你是许愿来的
因为过程中完全没有努力的记忆
只要把记忆的区块挖走
你拿到这个奖的重量都是虚的
再来你可许愿想去旅游哦
想去日本京都
或是想去海南岛度假
你许愿哦
哎一个礼拜后机票给你了
OK出发了就觉得哪里不对了
你也不会说啊天呐
因为你没有筹备
你没有规划
你没有存钱
你没有跟同学朋友讨论
你就拿到票了
因为你许愿想要去海南岛
记得这个就是人生相对应的合理处或公平处
你一定要付出代价
代价的过程中就会有挫折
挫折就会形成记忆
记忆就是你快乐对比的来源
越辛苦越挥汗如雨的训练
拿到成功的果实越甜美
所以你就不能随心所欲嘛
随心所欲很可怕
就是你任何事情只要许个愿
然后就能达到了
你绝对不会珍惜
举个极端的例子
赌博
我告诉你
赌博赢来的钱
你不会把它当钱花
你赢了10万人民币又怎么样
你不会把它当做工作薪水存的10万块花
因为你工作的所得是很辛苦
上了一天的班
贡献了你的本职学
能拿到的扎实的相对应的报酬
可能1万人民币
可能6000人民币
你花了6000人民币就会花的很谨慎
但是你赌桌上赢来的10万块
你就不会把它当做10万块花
但是呢你输掉10万块的话
你就扎扎实实的输掉了第一个
你输掉的时间
输掉了人际关系
输掉了性格
然后输掉了对金钱的认知跟金钱正确的态度
所以赌博怎么能赢呢
所以我刚刚举的例子有听懂吗
或者是理解
就是因为你不能随心所欲
所以呢人生面临各种挑战才有趣
假设有个水晶球
你可以透过水晶球看到两年后的你跟谁恋爱
3年后的你从事什么工作
5年后的你什么生活状态
比如说居住在小区
哪个小区
哪个地段房价多少
你透过水晶球都看得到
我跟你讲这个灾难多可怕
你没有对未知的期待了
你没有持续前进的动力了
当人生的画面已经定格
已经不可逆的时候
请问你对生活的想象和热情怎么继续燃烧
现在这个女朋友是他女朋友吗
现在这个暧昧的对象还要继续吗
你看到水晶球了
两年后的交往对象是谁
你看到了这个人要珍惜吗
还是还是3年后的工作
看到了
那这个工作还会继续干
还会继续努力
那个就是灾难了
就是因为我们不能随心所欲
你面对的都是新的
你怎么知道你两年后认识什么朋友
一个月后接到什么案子
那个案子的状况是什么样的结构
然后3年后你有什么样的旅游计划
或是婚姻的状态
或是情感的状态
你都不晓得
那人就是因为这样才有趣啊
就是你的一切都未知
要靠自己去争取
任何的努力
都是人生风景
那个区块
任何事物是不是要亲自去感受
亲自去争取
留下的果实才有意义
正如今天的课程一体
当个有故事可以说的人
怎么样累积故事呢
你就是去感受生活周遭所有的挫折
所有的困难
因为你去感受挫折
困难的时候
你会成长
你会收获
而这些成长和收获
都会变成你人生风景的一个区块
一个拼图
就是说你可能有挫折的拼图
有开心的拼图
有成功的拼图
有朋友相聚的拼图
拼起来才是完整的人生
人生就像戏剧一样
一定有起伏
一定要跌宕
不肯从头到尾顺遂一本完全具体
没有高潮迭起
主角没有受到困难的一个小说
你谁还要看呢
张杰上的翻译就没兴趣了嘛
我就觉得说如果写的每一首歌都不用修改
那我其实不会进步
因为修改就会被要求嘛
那如果每次执行的案子都很顺遂
那从那我就不晓得我的缺点在哪里
那我就没有办法说得更进步
这些生活相关的一些事物
有时候你觉得它就存在了
然后他就觉得很寻常
也不需要特别的变成一个意义来讨论
但是我不会这样认为
我很喜欢观察
我很喜欢观察人坐在咖啡厅里面
然后拿一个咖啡喝一个下午
我可观察到四五个人
变成你创作的一个灵感来源
或者是你对照自己的生活
因为本身就是一个故事可以说的人
但我故事的来源是什么
就是我的生活历练
就是我生活的遭遇啊
就是我创作者遇到的困难
就是我熬尽脑汁的作品被退稿了
我重写了一份
重写一份的过程
你就有所谓的记忆了
他这个记忆是别人偷不走的
因为是你的经验
是你的成长
是你文字结构的一种进步
就像你去学个篮球
学个运动技能一样
你一定要真的去学习学习的这个经验跟技术
是别人偷不走
你许愿没有用
你许愿是拿到了成果
但是过程中的经验和累积你没有吸收
就像刚刚那句话一样
人生就是因为不能随心所欲
那你不能随心所欲的时候
你能干嘛
你就按部就班嘛
你就合理的进行你生涯中各个领域的规划
就像你喜欢作词好
你报名的歌词创作班经历了这30堂课了
相信你从技术面上态度上一定有收获
这是你自己付出的哦
你有看了歌词创作班的故事哦
纵使是一堂课
你也有属于你自己的故事
你自己的人生故事
因为你付出了时间
因为你付出了吸收的态度跟观察
甚至你做了笔记
自己吸收一项专门领域的知识
这个风景是不一样的
人的一生会遇到很多的人事地物
那这个人死地物都是一块一块的风景
当初在台北发展是一个记忆
然后每天骑车是一个记忆
那这些记忆就变成组成我的一部分
那每个人同学们有自己的记忆
在生活中有自己的困难
有自己的朋友圈
有自己的生活价值和人生态度
今天再加上这堂课程
又更丰富了你的生活历练
这些无形中的累积就是你人生的记忆
而这个记忆就会让你成为一个有故事
可以说的
不要到了五六十岁的时候
回顾一生
发现你里面有故事
可以说自己人生很顺利
而且顺利到没有故事
可以说我觉得那个很可怕
因为每个人只能活一次
只能在你的人生轨道里面行走一遍
那是行走一遍的过程中
你居然没有累积出自己所需要的技术记忆
风景跟人际关系
这样子的人生态度不是很浪费吗
很对不起自己吗
如果自己可以分饰两角
就像我面对问题的时候
我肩膀上都有两个人
应该说这样做对吗
有说这样做不对吧
这是确实的
创作的时候
也是面临选择的时候
都会有一个正面的声音
有个负面的声音
但不是说负面的声音是一种态度了
不是说他一定是错的
而是说这样做好像不好
这样做一定可以的
就是比较乐观的声音
比较谨慎的声音
因为我在面对问题的时候
我想要取得一个最好的解决
通常这些解决就会累积的
我一直强调的记忆风景
就会请说出你该有的人生故事
相信报名歌词创作班的同学们应该都很年轻
可能20几岁
可能30出头
相对于我而言
我已经50几岁了
50出头了
你们比我年轻了20岁
30岁
天呐
你们居然有20年30年的时间
可以好好地吸收一门学问
可以追求自己定定的目标
真的很幸福啊
也就是说你们时间的红利大鱼太多了
居然手里面握着20年30年的时间红利
你可以尽情的吸收在这个时空背景
追求自己的兴趣
吸收自己要的领域
然后慢慢的20年30年后
你在这个职场上
在社会上有自己的位置
有自己的声望
有自己的角色定位
再回过头来想20年30年前的这堂课
歌词创作班
你我共同经历的这段时间
这是我们共同累积的记忆
也是你跟我共同酝酿的人生故事
是不是很特别
因为你报名的歌词创作班
你更了解了我
而透过了解我
你也学习到歌词创作累积的观察
训练的独立判断的能力
还有粗略旁通各个领域
这些会有价值的
5年后
10年后
20年后再来回想今天的课程
它的价值是发酵的
会存在你的记忆深处
因为我们共同享受了这段学习时光
里面的人生故事
最后分享一段比较感性的词句
因为作词人的职业本能
我在创作诗的时候
我就赋予他韵脚诗
我在创作座右铭的时候会压的韵脚
所以这段感性的文案呢
他也压得很轻盈的韵脚
这世界正因为日夜会交替
因为有四季
因为有风有雨
所以我们拥有一段不同的过去
如果花不会凋谢
人不会老去
青春不会远离
我们将拥有一样的记忆
亲爱的
一场永不落幕的花季
再怎么艳丽
也不会有人珍惜
所以幸福时我们手紧握在一起
难过时放声哭泣
会凋谢的花季
也才有被期待的惊喜